blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman so we're going to talk today
about
the outlook politically in the united
states over the next couple of election
cycles and we're going to have two very
different conversations in this first
segment first i'm going to talk about
um
what i believe is an overtly black and
white
approach
to figuring out what the general
strategy of the left should be over the
next couple of election cycles based on
what happened tuesday the second piece
of it is going to be very tactical
actually it's going to be very much
about
talking points and
how to fight
on very specific issues the messaging of
the right both of these are important
but let's start with the bigger picture
first
there are two
uh conflicting interpretations that are
being repeated
uncritically in a sense about what
happened on tuesday now what happened on
tuesday was very bad for democrats and
it bodes very poorly it it does not
signal that 2022 is going to be great
for democrats and maybe even 2024 and
we'll talk about that a little bit later
but one reaction to what happened
tuesday is
whoa
democrats went too far left india walton
socialist in buffalo new york got got
defeated easily by a write-in candidate
democrats need to come back to the
middle
the reaction by many to what happened in
virginia terry mcauliffe losing there to
glen yunkin after
ralph northam won by nine in 2017.
democrat one by nine now republican
ended up winning by a couple of points
the reaction there has been democrats
need to go further to the left this
centrist establishment
milk toast terry mcauliffe that's not
what is going to lead democrats to
victory in the future
and the truth is the world is just more
complicated than that and unfortunately
partially because of the way corporate
media is structured and functions and
partially because we have a tendency to
want simple uh one factor explanations
for things
a lot of these false black white
dichotomies are not going to lead to any
success for the left which ultimately is
what i care about so let's look at a
couple of examples um here's one
headline
uh from common dreams which says
progressives on the virginia loss
corporate democrats have only themselves
to blame
uh it's conservative dems who've ensured
that every day for the last several
months the headlines are about how we
aren't delivering paid leave
prescription drug reform elder care or
voting rights and that the problem is
that if the democratic candidate
had been much more to the left in
virginia
virginia would have been held by
democrats and we're going to link to
this article
and you can analyze it and think about
it contrasting narrative
is about socialist india walton in
buffalo was a bad idea incumbent brown
declares buffalo mayor wright and win
over socialist india walton this is a
new york post article new york post is
sort of like fox news owned by news
corporation the incumbent democratic
mayor of buffalo running as a write-in
candidate declared victory tuesday night
as he held a nearly 20-point lead over
his democratic party opponent india
walton a socialist backed by many
high-profile progressives refused to
concede to mayor brown in the highly
publicized contest until her campaign
sees all the votes
um and this has led to a number of
arguments that the problem is that
that's too far left now here's the
reality both are true
both are true how can both be true well
it is true
that socialism isn't very popular in the
united states and right now there aren't
many socialists and that could be a
factor in buffalo it's it's plausible
that in buffalo
one of the reasons that india walton
didn't win and lost to a write-in
candidate is that there's not that many
socialists in buffalo and we learned
from the 2020 democratic party that
ideas a democratic primary rather ideas
that seem popular on twitter and reddit
are not actually as popular among the
average democratic voter that is true in
a sense and india walton being a
socialist could be a factor now some are
saying race is a factor although the the
incumbent
is black
uh and there's all sorts of different
arguments being made but
at least when it comes to
the buffalo mayoral race it doesn't seem
that being a socialist helped india
walton so that's a consideration
at the same time
terry mcauliffe was a milk toast
uninspiring centrist democrat in
virginia
and that was a factor there there were
also other factors in virginia the fact
that the election for a long period of
time was run as a sort of referendum on
trump when trump wasn't even running and
junkin was sort of careful not to
denounce nor embrace donald trump so
that was a factor um there were a lot of
different factors the fact that the
right very successfully played on fear
and anger over critical race theory
which isn't even being taught to kids in
virginia okay but the common thread in
both elections is that voters were
motivated by fear and anger to vote
for someone other than terry mcauliffe
in virginia
and india walton in buffalo new york
fear and anger motivate people
more effectively than hey we're going to
do green energy
or
we're going to
replace some police with social workers
or whatever the case may be
in buffalo it was sort of traditional
democrat byron brown who did it
and said
you don't want that you don't want that
you did this is safer that's dangerous
you should be afraid of that in virginia
it was radical republican glenn young in
different populations virginia is more
of a 50 50 state overall
buffalo is a pr i believe joe biden got
like 77 percent of the vote or no maybe
it was 67. joe biden won buffalo easily
in 2020 but it's more democratic
establishment rather than like
progressive socialist democrats so
yes democrats ran a terrible campaign in
virginia focused on trump who wasn't
really involved mcauliffe could have won
if the climate were actually we are
running against trump the way biden did
that's totally plausible we'd be having
a different conversation right now
but the takeaway here is
the democratic party electorate is more
centrist than it seems on twitter and
reddit we learned that in the 2020
primary but at the same time there is no
one explanation as to what democrats
need to do and the first mistake if we
even want to have this conversation is
we can't restrict ourselves to an
analysis analysis that is
to win democrats need to move to the
middle or to win democrats need to move
to the left
there is not one thing democrats need to
do and in mayoral elections versus state
senate and rep
versus senate and house of
representatives governor and president
there is not one answer and unless we
can first agree there is not one answer
we're probably not going to get more
productive conversations unfortunately
so let's now get from
strategy and approach to tactics
i got a really interesting email from
eric and colleen i think eric and
colleen are a couple that watch the show
and what eric and colleen wrote to me
about was
the new democratic talking points they
seem to understand that democrats have
been falling to republicans in many
cases because republicans much more
effectively play on fear and anger and
that republican talking points just
naturally lend themselves more to that
and eric and colleen wrote to me and
said david you know if you if we want to
develop on the left the same motivating
fear and anger that the republican party
does we need to change our messaging now
eric and colleen say
it doesn't even matter if our messaging
is true republicans lie all the time so
my question to you as i go through these
possible talking points that eric and
colleen suggested is
how do we feel about using talking
points that we know in some cases aren't
true
is that taking the low road and and we
don't want to do it but here are the new
talking points that eric and colleen
suggest should be repeated and repeated
and repeated in 2022 and 2024 on
abortion okay these are hypothetical
talking boys on abortion republicans
want to force you to have babies
and they will create a dangerous and
expensive black market of back alley
abortions
it's not really an exaggeration actually
it's using maybe hyperbolic language but
that one isn't wrong
on guns republicans will make it so easy
to get guns
that every criminal will be armed and
many of those will be armed with
semi-automatics outfitted with
high-capacity magazines
every criminal will be armed it's an
exaggeration but certainly the right
wants to make it really easy to get guns
on immigration republicans will shut
down the borders
women and children who are fleeing
violence are going to die at the border
of disease and starvation or be sent
back to death
in their home countries
hyperbolic but it plays on fear and it
plays on anger education
republicans will take control away from
school boards and implement a federal
government curriculum it won't be based
in science it won't be based in accurate
historical realities it's going to be
alternative facts lies and christianity
and they will impose it on your children
on the pandemic
republicans will not allow enforcement
of any safety measure they will ban mask
requirements they will ban vaccine
requirements and they are going to allow
this or a future pandemic to run rampant
they will allow innocent americans to
keep dying just to avoid implementing
any regulations
on deregulation republicans are going to
let poison and sewage pour into our
water systems they're going to build
more fossil fuel plants near your homes
and there will be more respiratory
disease and cancer as a result
on inequality
republicans will allow
wealth concentration to deepen and it
will destroy the middle class
that one seems just pretty pretty sober
actually
on taxes republicans will continue to
allow the rich and corporations to get
away with paying no taxes or close to it
the rich will get richer concentration
of power will become worse and it will
crush the middle class and lastly on
infrastructure the talking point
proposed by eric and colleen is our
infrastructure roads electrical grid
military educational system it will be
bankrupt thanks to the rich in
corporations paying almost no taxes
this is more hyperbolic language than
democrats on the left tend to use
it's mostly accurate with some
exaggerations
how do you feel about it are these
do
democrats and does the left
need
to find talking points to generate that
exact same type of fear and anger that
the right does without and outlies and
if the answer is yes the left needs to
do that
does the left need to do it
without exaggeration and without
hyperbole or is it okay
to do it the way eric and colleen are
suggesting let me know your thoughts let
me know what talking points you think
the left should adopt you can find me on
twitter at dpakman and we'll be back
with more right after this
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
you can join the david pakman show
subreddit davidpakman.com
slash reddit r-e-d-d-i-t
nearly uh what are we up to it must be
about 33-34
000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed there a couple of interesting
posts and discussions i spotted this
morning one is from user dl1943
who says does anyone know where i can
find explanations for the jfk junior
stuff i'm totally fascinated by
conspiracy theories and always have been
obviously i do not believe in q anon or
really any straight up conspiracies but
i'd like to hear this whole jfk junior
stuff laid out by the people who believe
it not regurgitated through media
articles does anyone know of any
publicly viewable sites where the q
people post about this stuff or discuss
it yeah so listen my understanding is
that a bunch of i guess q anon type
people
believe that jfk jr who was killed in a
plane crash in
1999 i think it was
is actually still alive
some of them believed that
he was going to be running alongside
trump at some point or was in 2020 in
some kind of secret way or there's a
million different iterations of this
and then others believed that he was
going to reappear
um i guess near the grassy
knoll in dallas texas a couple of days
ago and they actually gathered there
uh that's sort of like my best
understanding of it and i don't know if
there's any other
specific
reason why it's jfk jr
there was some confusion because a lot
of the very same people who believe that
and are part of q anon are also
anti-vaxx
and
a really funny thing seems to be in one
i don't remember if it was in the
comments on a rumble post or some
right-wing enclave i could tell from the
comments that there were people confused
between this uh
jfk junior conspiracy
and the fact that
bobby kennedy jr is anti-vaxx
and it was just like a whole confusion
it was almost like um
q-ception i would call it where even the
q people were confused about the
concatenated conspiracy theories okay
anyway so that's my best understanding
but you know you you might be able to
find something clearer from someone who
actually believes it
a user mgsf departed posted to the
subreddit
why younkins at the time it was probable
but now it's now it's now we know it's
victory why youncan's victory needs to
be taken seriously
and they write yunkan had absolutely
nothing to run on nothing of actual
concrete substance just culture war
noises and a whole lot of old-fashioned
lies
he's still ahead by over a hundred
thousand votes he ran all of the best
worst hits from ending critical race
theory which doesn't exist in virginia
reinstating family values a meaningless
talking point attacking teachers
and using things like critical race
theory as a blanket excuse to cut
funding meant to raise wages for
teachers and the idiots ate it up
i'm sure you've already seen the bumpkin
getting interviewed who said i don't
care much for crt while on the other
side of his mouth adding he has no clue
what it is it doesn't matter it's a
non-issue and it's one idiot's i guess
they mean cling to the reality is simple
with or without the bs culture war
noises these idiots were all going to
turn out in droves for yunkan regardless
they're pissed and more importantly
they're galvanized they've been bashed
over what's left of their brains
multiple times into thinking their
voices weren't heard and now they're
turning out in droves it's not yet known
if democrats just didn't turn out or if
the numbers were not in their favor but
this was a win for the gqp and if it
really is an indicator of what's to come
next year we're in trouble
if junkin does emerge victorious which
he did and in active policies he's
trying to or tries to enact them then
the left needs to shine a spotlight on
it and use that to light the necessary
fires under our asses because the gqp
has gone full stone age on us and if
people remain apathetic combined with
voter suppression we're going to see a
lot
this won't stay in virginia
uh this this is absolutely correct
there's just uh i have so little to add
other than i did add on to it in the
first two segments on today's show
the answer is not always run further to
the left the answer is not always run
further to the to the middle it depends
on the race
there's not a one size fits all approach
but the one size fits all approach that
the right is implementing is the one we
have to fight and that is fear and anger
over things that are completely untrue
that are being exaggerated or misstated
or simply misunderstood by republican
voters and it's really really hard to
fight that i don't have the answer i
proposed a couple possibilities earlier
but i don't have the answer but i think
this assessment is spot on anybody's
saying anybody downplaying
the effect or the significance of
tuesday's elections for democrats for
2022 even 2024 you could have a big
wake-up call it's going to be very ugly
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit
there is a new report it's an extremely
disturbing report which found that at
least eight republicans who were at the
january sixth rally
have been elected to office now these
are not
necessarily people who were
participating in the riot
um but these are folks who were at the
rally on january 6. huffington post
article
at least eight republicans who were
elected at the rally just got elected to
office and even more attendees of the
rally that turned into the riot will
likely be on the ballot in 2022
although most have claimed they didn't
breach the u.s capitol on that day all
were participants in the demonstration
leading up to the attack standing
alongside extremists to take part in the
finale of a months-long anti-democratic
campaign to falsely claim that then
president donald trump didn't really
lose 2020.
their victories on tuesday are a
possible sign of things to come huffpost
previously identified
57 state and local republican officials
who attended the rally many of whom will
be up for re-election and likely will
win next year
that these candidates enjoy the support
of the wider republican party and are
winning elections does not bode well for
american democracy that's an
understatement
showing that one of the country's major
political parties
despite some initial gestures that being
horrified by the events of january 6 is
almost completely unrepentant over its
role in fomenting the historic attack on
the capital and why wouldn't they there
have barely been consequences as i said
before
um not only barely consequences
for the perpetrators many of their cases
still pending
um but no real consequences for the
insiders and some of them are getting
rewarded by getting elected
among the january sixth attendees who
won office on tuesday were two
republicans re-elected to the virginia
house of delegates dave larocque and
john mcguire
um marie march a restaurant owner who
bragged about her attendance at the stop
the steel rally and who in a since
deleted facebook post warned of a coming
civil war in which she would be willing
to fight and die for both her family and
small businesses also won a seat in the
virginia house of delegates on tuesday
in city councils across the country
rally attendee natalie jangula won a
seat in nampa idaho christine eid who
didn't go into the capital
and later blamed the violence on antifa
won a seat in watchung new jersey
charles osberger
also won a seat on the town council of
mansfield connecticut susan soloway
organized transportation to the rally
won re-election to the hunterdon county
new jersey board of directors
in braintree massachusetts a former high
school teacher who resigned his position
after local activists sent a photo of
him outside the capitol won a seat on
the local school committee it goes on
and on and on
this is a really backwards time now just
an example of someone elected to give
you a sense of the caliber of these
people this is not someone
from the rally this is just an example
of a republican that
um
voters liked enough to elect this is new
jersey truck driver edward durr
who was just elected a republican state
senator
and when he was asked well what are you
gonna do
in trenton he said i don't really know i
don't i have no idea this this is who is
now in a position of power take a look
at this he chose to sit back and do
nothing ed what's the first thing you're
going to do when you get to the capitol
in trenton
uh i really don't know that's that's the
key factor i don't know what i don't
know so that is the key factor we'll
learn what i need to know
and i'm going to
guarantee you one thing yeah i will be
the voice and people will hear me
because if there's one thing people will
learn about me i got a big mouth and i
don't shut up when i want to be heard
i'm going to be heard
this is not a lot the [ __ ] the host is
laughing
this is horrifying guys
i will let
go ahead go ahead no you go ahead finish
your thought oh my god i was just going
to say that i i will be that voice for
the people because i chose to sit back
oh man
um
i wasn't kidding yesterday with my 2030
rant and the rant sort of was
this week's elections might set the tone
for some major republican wins in 2022
which could include taking control back
of the house and senate
i've already said 2024 with biden or
harris as the democratic nominees
it's looking dubious to me
you could see
republicans take the house and senate in
22
and the white house in 24 and then in 26
democrats are really going to be up
against the wall and republicans will
have continued damaging the environment
in the country it could be a very tough
eight to ten years for this country and
again i said this on a stream there are
some people who are mad and some people
who agreed
in many blue states things are going to
be fine this is not blue state elitism
and me saying i don't have to worry
because i live in blue states it's an
empirical reality that if you look at
the human development index of
massachusetts it's the same as norway
quality of life is like norway
connecticut has the hdi ranking of
switzerland
minnesota
new hampshire connecticut they have the
human development index ranking of
germany and hong kong
new york is equivalent to australia and
the netherlands
in lots of those places many things are
going to be mostly fine
but stuff like pollution and so many
others that cross state lines are going
to be really bad everywhere and
i still care about people in red states
do that have the equivalent you know
standard of living of much poorer
countries so could be ugly for a long
time
and um
the last 96 hours aren't pointing in a
great direction make sure you're
following us on instagram at david
pakman show we'll be back right after
this short break
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's great to have back on the program
today brian class who's an associate
professor of global politics at
university college london and also
author of the new book corruptable who
gets power and how it changes us brian
always great to talk to you
thanks for having me so you know when we
think about something like who obtains
power in in society we could even narrow
it down and say in kind of western
democracies in capitalist western
democracies there's a lot of different
approaches we can look at we we can look
at sort of psychological factors and
personality factors about individuals we
can talk about um you know the leg up
that the economic circumstances that one
is born into might
play as a factor uh we we can talk about
the role of media so many different
things
what are some of the or maybe the most
important filters through which we can
start to think about who ends up holding
power in society
yes so i think that the
most of the debate around people in
power is like a tip of the iceberg
problem where we tend to focus almost
all of our attention on the people who
are actually in power the ones who we
can see right the top of the iceberg and
the real problem i think we have is
underneath the surface which is the
people who don't seek power
and so you know you think about like a
high school basketball team you never
expect that basketball team to be a
representative sample of height in the
school right there's a certain group of
people that are going to try out for the
team the same is obviously true with
power now i've looked you know the book
draws on a wide variety of research from
evolutionary biology to neuroscience and
psychology and so on so i started to ask
people who study this is there a power
gene is there something in us
that causes us to seek power and there
is a study that shows a significant
correlation between a specific gene and
people who end up in power but we can't
say whether that's because they have
certain traits they're more outgoing
they're more affable whatever but we do
have some evidence that there is some
genetic basis to power attainment and
then of course you filter that through
all the stuff in society where
you know i mean it's obvious that white
men are have an easier time getting
power in western democracies
but also that we seek certain things uh
in in our rulers and and this ranges
from everything from evolutionary
psychology where we look at you know why
is it that we turn to strong men in
times of crises
to
this amazing study i found about
basically asking children to pick
someone to captain their imaginary ship
in this computer simulation and they
basically are shown two faces
and there's no other information given
they pick one of the faces to be the
captain what they don't know is that the
two faces are the winner and the
runner-up of the french parliamentary
elections
and with astonishing accuracy they tend
to pick the winner which reflects this
horrible truth that often we have such
superficial assessments when we pick
leaders so
there are dozens of reasons why this
happens but i think we have to
acknowledge the problem and the
self-selection that goes into power
before we can actually fix it with some
of these things there would be sort of a
legitimate question to ask about
uh it's sort of like a chicken egg thing
uh and i'll explain what i mean when we
think about the alleged uh corrupting
influence of power
it's often said that absolute power
corrupts but is there something about
corrupt people who are already corrupt
predisposed to put themselves
in those positions that kind of reverses
the causation
yeah so i'll answer with in two ways the
first is that there's this there's this
other study that i found phenomenal
where it basically asks people to roll a
dice and it says if you roll a six you
get more money if you roll a wine you
get no money right so there's an
incentive to lie about it so they you
know there's variations of how many
people cheat in this basically but what
they found was that when they ran this
study in corrupt countries like in india
where being a civil servant is somewhere
where you can get off the books pay
what happened was the people who lied
about their dice rolls were
disproportionately likely to want to
become civil servants they did this at a
school
if you do the exact same study in
somewhere like denmark it's exactly the
opposite the people who report their
stores complete their scores completely
honestly they're the ones who want to go
into public service so a corrupt system
draws in corrupt people and a clean
system draws in clean people so the
system really really matters i talk
about this actually in an essay i have
out in the atlantic today with policing
in the united states so there's this
there's this phenomenon that i think
doesn't get enough attention when we
talk about body cameras and trying to
change what the police do with police
reforms and we have to think about who
the police are and who wants to become a
police officer
so you know i looked at this ad that was
used for recruitment in doraville
georgia this this town of 10 000 people
outside atlanta atlanta and it's i mean
it's a caricature right it's literally
like these guys in a tank driving
through
uh in the sort of you know the punisher
logo is flashing on screen about
vigilante justice they throw smoke
grenades out that's you know that's the
image of policing
i talked to new zealand's police force
and they basically tried to counteract
this so they ran
a multi-year recruitment scheme that
used funny videos made policing look
enjoyable all about public service had
lots of women and ethnic minorities in
it and their applications shot through
the roof fernand through the roof for
non-traditional officers and their abuse
levels uh fell at the same time so you
know i think that there's
an acknowledgement we have to make that
the way we perceive systems of power
really really matters for who seeks it
and it's why i'm particularly worried
about what's happening in the u.s right
now with these insane zealots
threatening school board members for you
know mass mandates and so on because
they're making public service toxic and
they're going to ensure that good decent
people just simply self-select out of
systems of power and that we're left
with the people who the insane zealots
basically agree with putting their hat
in the ring right you have that issue
you also have i mean it's not
necessarily related to what we're
talking about here but i've pointed out
that those who want to hurt public
education funded through taxes love the
school board stuff because they see it
as hey if if these schools seem really
chaotic it might encourage parents to
say i'm pulling my kid out i'm going to
do homeschooling private school whatever
which will of course further weaken
schools and and sort of sort of
exacerbate let's go back a little bit to
the police thing because that's
interesting and you've talked about that
um
there recently two stories on policing
have sort of come together one is what
was sort of increased by the george
floyd protests and questions of police
brutality and bad apples that spawned
the that spoiled the bunch etc we also
have
the anti-vaccine stuff which is leading
to it really doesn't seem like more than
one percent in the worst cases of
officers leaving you know 34 officers in
new york city out of 36 000
a few emails that came in people said
hey you know when we talk about the bad
apples that spoil the bunch on the
police brutality stuff it might be the
same people who are now leaving because
of the vaccine stuff this could be a
blessing in disguise but that's not
really a strategy for dealing with with
this issue of policing what is your
sense of you know there's the reform
movement there's the uh defund movement
there's all these different ideas and
approaches you mentioned one in in new
zealand that was a very different
approach how should we be thinking about
big picture the issue of policing in the
united states and who is doing the
policing
yeah so i mean the stuff i talked about
new zealand is a first step which is to
say you need to make the police
appealing to normal decent people who
want to serve the public that don't have
a military background right veterans are
overrepresented in the police
dramatically in the u.s by design by the
way and that's not necessarily a problem
it's just that you know if you think
that your job is the same as when you're
patrolling fallujah when you're in
ferguson
that's going to be an issue you're going
to be more likely to be a little
trigger-happy and so on and we need a
lot more community officers that have no
background in the military and actually
don't want power so the recruitment is
part of it there's other stuff i write
about in the book that's about how you
sort of deter abuses for people once
they're in power
you know i think it is easier to recruit
good apples than it is to make bad
apples behave better but we do have bad
apples in the police so what are we
going to do one of the keys is rotation
so there's a lot of studies that look at
how
comfort and sort of closed systems
create abuse so in police for example
this is the sort of blue wall of silence
and the sort of your partner will always
have your back even if you're doing
something really illegal and abusive so
the metropolitan police in london for
example did some work of rotating
partners uh through regularly and it had
really good results and there's also
loads of psychological research where
you have
participants play games basically in
which they can collude in order to win
money
and if you work with the same person
through multiple rounds of the game the
odds that you're going to try to give
bribes to win the game go massively
through the roof compared to if you're
constantly rotating people through
because you have you know this sort of
fresh face that you don't know is
necessarily on your side and
interestingly this data shows the same
thing whether they run it in germany or
china or the u.s so you know i have at
the end of the book there's this section
on on 10 ways to fix the problem and
they're basically things that all need
to happen because there's no silver
bullet this is a massive problem
but the point that i'm trying to make
here is that we don't think about
systems of power enough this way we have
to design every single system from the
police to politics with the assumption
which is true by the way that bad people
are disproportionately likely to seek
power disproportionately likely to get
it and disproportionately likely to be
able to stay in it longer than they
should and so once you take that as the
starting point then you redesign the
system and think how can we invert that
and i think nothing has been tried i
mean that that's the thing that i find
so
maddening is that all of the debates
around police
i mean there's some defund movements and
so on that have their ideas about you
know fundamentally transforming policing
but the rest of them body cameras i mean
it's a good idea but is that really
going to solve the problem there's a
thousand people who are getting killed
by cops in the united states every year
in new zealand there's about a dozen a
decade right maybe less than that so
obviously the population's different but
we have a massive massive problem on our
hands and i don't think around the edges
or forms are going to solve it what are
the different fields in which these
dynamics uh are are a problem and i
think police is one that gets a lot of
attention politicians and and you know
psychopathy predispositions is sometimes
talked about i think corporate ceos is
one that gets discussion we don't hear
about this dynamic among postal workers
or nurses for example so like what what
are the other fields where these
dynamics uh show up more
well it's it's very interesting you ask
that because there's there's two
sections in the book where i try to
bring this dynamic much closer to home
and there's one which is a really crazy
story uh about this guy named steve
rauchi who is a psychopathic custodian
in schenectady new york and in order to
raise rise to the ranks in his school
district
did some crazy stuff i mean he started
using explosives and all he's in jail
for a very long time now um and and that
job that was just a personality trait so
that's if you have a psychopath who's
power hungry you put them in anywhere
and they're gonna try to rise through
the ranks through any means necessary
but there's actually as you say a trait
to this that is disproportionately
selecting in certain jobs so politics is
an obvious one but also one that's
really interesting is a place where you
have power for the sake of power with no
real other benefits so i explore this
with homeowners associations there's a
great uh a great series of stories that
i've discovered and and characters that
are very interesting people who
basically you know it's it's like this
horrible job where you you spend your
time trying to impose fines on somebody
down the block who put their bin out you
know 10 minutes too early or something
on a sunday
who's that going to appeal to when the
pay is either non-existent or terrible
well it's the person who's power hungry
and can't fulfill that in another area
of life so
those types of positions are also
magnets for power abusers which is why
you get what we call the petty tyrants
effect the person who rules over a
completely insignificant domain but is
going to abuse every possible ounce of
power that they have and i think that's
something that a lot of people
experience in their daily lives
as a as a general rule are
the approaches that are more likely or
have worked more effectively about as
you mentioned with police it's higher
good apples rather than convert
it does that apply universally
yeah you you sort of need to do all of
the above to be honest because
the problem is not just the individual
it's also the system right i mean if you
have a good person who goes into a
rotten police department they're going
to probably behave in a rotten way and
one of the more unusual things that i
did that might be of interest to your
your viewers and listeners is i took a
ski lesson with paul bremmer who ran
iraq in 2003 and now he's a ski
instructor in vermont believe it or not
so he's an interesting case study
because you know a lot of people see him
as the villain and i understand
completely why i mean what he did in
2003 you know the the record speaks for
itself
but what's interesting about him is that
he was previously an ambassador to
malawi and norway and it appears that he
did a very good job i mean across most
people think that he was really
effective
and sort of had lots of integrity in
that position and so on and then he goes
into iraq where everything is broken and
he's basically you know a de facto
viceroy of a dictatorship and all of a
sudden everything he has to do is these
awful decisions with morally dubious
consequences and so on and so i think
one of the things that we also have to
acknowledge it's not to absolve people
who do bad things in positions of power
it's that it's more complicated
sometimes than it initially appears and
that the system also needs our attention
because
you know i i like to think that i would
behave well no matter what but you know
you see the evidence from around the
world and you you take people and put
them in new systems and they do behave
in different ways there's a study of
bankers in italy where southern italy is
known as being more corrupt than
northern italy yes and the employees who
move between the same bank but different
branches start embezzling at higher
rates if they're in the south so you
know there's things like that where we
can see that it's both the individual
and the system that need our attention
um
i i this may seem like a sort of
divergence but but i i think it it could
be an interesting one the role of power
within uh other species within within
the animal kingdom um what do we know
that mirrors homo sapiens and what what
differences are there
yeah it's a great question it's one of
the most enjoyable parts of the research
because you know i'm a political
scientist so i don't spend a lot of time
with people who study hyenas and bees
and primates and so on but i did for the
book yeah and
it was really really fascinating
primates are a great window for us
because it's
similar in terms of some of the brain
functions and some social structures
without the culture right and so uh you
can look at how power affects
individuals there's an amazing study i i
i interviewed a professor and doctor
uh out in north carolina who
looks at hierarchy and drug addiction in
macaque monkeys
and one of the craziest things is that
when you basically give monkeys you put
them in groups of four they instantly
form a hierarchy from one to four
and then you offer them the choice
between cocaine where they push a button
and they get intravenous cocaine or
banana pellets they push a different
button and they get banana pellets and
what's what's amazing about this is that
every time you run this study the top
two monkeys the ones that are on the top
of the hierarchy don't take the cocaine
they take the banana pellets the ones
who are on the bottom basically
self-medicate
and this happens even if the alpha male
in this group gets reassigned to another
group of four and then ends up on the
bottom all of a sudden the exact same
thing happens so it doesn't matter about
the individual i also looked at
corruption in believe it or not bees and
wasps and it's an amazing story about
systems and individual behavior i won't
go into the whole story but basically
the the gist of it is the way the hive
is set up between different kinds of
species of wasps whether it's
transparent or not whether it's easy to
detect wrongdoing or not by what are
actually called police wasps or police
bees
that has a massive massive effect on how
selfish the behavior of the individual
wasp or b is
and i think these lessons that we have
from the animal kingdom are actually
quite instructive because
most of the time when we talk about
these problems we're talking about them
within the silos of democrats and
republicans yeah and sometimes it's
worth stripping that away and saying
okay there's some universal lessons that
we can learn
and we might as well draw them from
wherever we can even if it's from an
unexpected place that's super
interesting yeah and and uh not that
long ago i read jared diamond's book the
third chimpanzee which also talks a lot
about um sort of the parts that are
analogous and parts that are not between
humans and and chimpanzees and there's
uh there's a lot of different layers to
that that you don't really see if the
focus is like american partisan politics
i guess is the point that you're making
yeah i mean i i think that there's some
some problems in society that actually
can be solved right i mean i think we
focus on so much stuff that is the
partisan battle of the day which makes
complete sense yeah but we can actually
make systems of power behave better for
all of us
and that requires some outside the box
thinking that might have reference
points that aren't our typical culture
wars right you know it's hard to get
worked up about uh you know somebody
making a point about the wasp corruption
for example it's not exactly gonna rile
you up in the same way
so i i think we can draw these lessons
the other point that i make by the way
is i as part of the research this book i
interviewed i met with lots of really
awful people i i met with lots of former
despots war criminals all sorts
around the world and one of the points
that i often make is you would find it
super weird if somebody who was an
expert on hyenas
never
encountered a hyena never studied one
never went up to one and observed it and
yet there's a lot of stuff in politics
where these monsters among us still are
living breathing and willing to talk to
people so i went to study them to figure
out what makes them tick and what power
does to them and i think we need to do
more of that because these problems are
preventable but we have to sort of strip
away some of the the sort of
preconceptions or
uh revulsion that we have and start to
think okay we're stuck with some of
these people how can we make them behave
better how can we replace them how can
we make sure that better people follow
them and that requires
some sort of outside the partisan frame
thinking i think
the book is corruptable who gets power
and how it changes us we've been
speaking with the book's author brian
class brian so great uh talking about
this and always really appreciate your
time
thanks david thanks for having me
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show all right
let's get through a couple other things
including a correction i'm gonna
apologize for something i said on the um
i think it was monday show which was
wrong but i'll get to that um i want to
look at an interview that was done last
night on fox news donald trump's uh i
was gonna say donald trump's former son
former president donald trump's son eric
trump still his son as far as we know
appeared on fox news last night and he
said a lot of things that don't make any
sense it was a humiliating interview it
was another one of these face plants
where
why does nobody go up to him and say you
know sir these interviews aren't making
you look particularly good i'm sure he
thinks this makes him look great but
let's just jump right into it the first
clip is based on the results of virginia
and the context here is really
interesting i mentioned at uh on monday
that win or lose in virginia donald
trump is going to claim that um he was
in the right and he sort of won on
virginia in the sense that trump
endorsed yunkan but yunkan did not
embrace trump's endorsement so i
predicted if yunkan loses trump will say
it's not really a loss for me because i
endorsed him but he didn't embrace it he
didn't accept it and if junkin wins
trump will say this is part of my great
track record on endorsements which is
not so good and we'll get to that in a
second eric trump playing right into
this and saying virginia was a great
night for trump he's not even pretending
that it's about anything else for him
what a great night this was for the u.s
and what a great night it was for uh
frankly trump but it's interesting
because your dad did endorse yunkan um
your dad's track record is probably
second to nobody when it comes to
yeah it's actually not a great record
trump likes to say i'm
152 or whatever on endorsements you can
look this stuff up um trump's
endorsements are widely documented in
the 2018 midterms trump endorsed 75
candidates and a little more than half
of them won 42 of the 75 won that's 55
that's not that great particularly when
you consider that
most endorsements are incumbents and
there's a big bias to success with
endorsements because they're already in
office and incumbency has a huge
advantage during trump's presidency
overall from 2017 to 21 to 2021 trump uh
endorsed 305 people and then after
leaving trump endorsed 49 people that's
a total of 354 endorsements overall
trump's somewhere between 65 and 75
percent and again there's a bias to
success because you mostly endorse
incumbents and incumbents usually win so
it's not really that great of a track
record but i i guess maybe no one's fact
checking it even trump over the weekend
said to janine pirro i think i'm a
hundred and forty something and two or
something like that janine perot doesn't
say a word about it
she may not know she may not care um
okay let's continue
here we go into the supply chain stuff
and with the supply chain stuff they're
not even pretending
that christmas is about anything other
than gifting cheap chinese goods to
people it's it's gonna ruin christmas
that chinese goods are stuck on ships
here's eric trump that's right because
he's an exciting guy and you know most
politicians quite frankly aren't and my
father finally brought some you know
practicality and a sense of realism to
politics that had never existed before
and you compare that to joe biden right
now who
while kids christmas presents are
sitting on ships outside the port of la
because they can't get ships into our
ports in this country and they have all
sorts of problems right yeah while
that's happening joe biden's over in
glasgow falling asleep at climate
summits right that needs to that has to
tell you everything you need to know
about a politician now again
that doesn't really have to do with joe
biden there were supply chain issues
under trump and their supply chain
issues now
nobody was blaming trump transportation
secretary elaine chao last year but now
they're blaming pete budej they weren't
blaming trump but now they're blaming
biden but the bigger story for me is is
is it are we
are we just admitting christmas is
actually about cheap chinese goods
brought over on container ships like are
we there's not even a pretense that
that's not really the most important
part of christmas i don't celebrate
christmas i don't know
but i always thought that at least some
people who celebrate christmas said it
was about something else that the spirit
of christmas was not cheap chinese good
stuck on ships okay continuing the
supply chain stuff eric trump says you
can't get heating oil and you can't get
gasoline anymore every product is
getting more and more expensive you
can't get pvc at a hardware store
because we're not getting in this
country i mean just the basic problems
this country has heating oil gasoline
everything you can't get it you can't
get everything anymore guys
i don't know if he thinks this makes him
look good but it doesn't and then lastly
eric trump even channeling trump now
with the verbal slips referring to
lieutenant governor as
lieutenant which is i kind of like
lieutenant lieutenant and we just have
an unbelievable night not just with
governor not just a lieutenant governor
[Laughter]
okay all right guys so that's that eric
trump completely humiliating himself all
right when i make a mistake on the show
and it's more than just you know i just
some kind of minor thing i want to make
sure i come to you and i say sirs and
mams
i made a mistake and i want to i want to
correct the record on monday i talked
about the glasgow
climate change summit and the outrage
over 400 private jets flying there and
the irony and hypocrisy of let's fix
climate
and let's talk about it by flying in on
our private jets which on a per person
basis the carbon expenditures are off
the charts and i said a lot of different
things in that segment including that
rich people are going to keep using
private jets and that the economics of
private jets just makes sense for ceos
and other dignitaries when you account
all different factors eventually private
jets can run on uh renewable fuels and
they're not going away and that the real
problem is that this is a distraction
sort of like change your straw and
recycle at home
i said this is a distraction from the
fact that um 100 companies are
responsible for 71 of all emissions
that was not accurate and i actually got
an email from samuel about this the
article that i put up on the screen is a
guardian article from four years ago
it's been widely shared and it says
100 companies are responsible for 71 of
global emissions a small number of
fossil fuel producers and their
investors could call the key to tackling
climate change this this is not
representative of the truth okay this
has actually been looked at i'm glad to
be corrected you can check out the
snopes article about it it's misleading
in the following sense
what the
actual data is is that within the
universe of fossil fuel producers
71
of the pollution from fossil fuel
producers
comes from just 100 companies it doesn't
account for all sorts of other types of
companies that also pollute
so when i said
100 companies are responsible for 71 of
pollution that's within fossil fuel
producers coal gas drilling etc
it doesn't account for everything the
analysis is still the same the analysis
is still
there are
corporations
that pollute either directly by mining
fossil fuels or indirectly through their
business models that would love it for
the attention to be on did you recycle
every milk carton or not
are you still using a plastic straw
rather than
the significant industrial pollution
that they contribute to so the analysis
is the same but that statistic 100
companies contribute to 71 of all
pollution no it's within fossil fuels in
the within the fossil fuel industry 71
of that pollution comes from 100 fossil
fuel producers
i'm sorry
uh the analysis is the same but it would
have been stronger had i not cited that
and i'm gonna do better in the future we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 david p
one of the things that bothers me the
most about the ignorance that pervades
our society
is when people call in and they
criticize me for things i haven't set
for points i haven't actually made
criticize me for things i've said and do
it factually and then we'll have a good
conversation the san antonio troll is
someone who makes a habit of this he
calls in all the time and he often will
criticize me for things i didn't say
sometimes it's things maybe from other
shows that he watched and in this case
he criticizes me for saying
india walton would have won if she had
been more of a socialist i never said
that i'm not a socialist i don't believe
running as more of a socialist would
have helped her but that's still what
i'm getting criticized for take a listen
to this it's sad
uh pac-man i you know
i i just i'm sorry to call again man you
know who this is it's just you don't
even have to play that this thing didn't
give my voice to you i am
my mind is blown listen to your video
dude like your take with india walton
losing the buffalo metal rice
your take is that
these candidates aren't socialists
enough she lost to a writing candidate
like and your take is all they need to
be more socialism like bro
i never said that
i never said that uh i don't even know
where he could have gotten it did
someone else say it i don't really watch
other shows like mine but is there or
one of did one of my colleagues
say that india walton would have won if
she had been more socialist
it's just not my analysis criticize me
for things i've said let's listen to a
little bit more dude it's time to like
just
i get it these opinions like hating the
father
hating the flag hating the family hating
the police
hating capitalism
must be ta has to be talking about some
other show right hating the big
corporation i understand these are very
popular opinions on like twitter reddit
and discord and and youtube even but
look man it just doesn't want elections
dude people are like
hey you know i love my family you know i
don't want to
go talk to someone who's actually making
these claims that would be my advice to
the san antonio troll we've got a great
bonus show for you today there is one
republican senator ready to vote to move
forward with uh debating a major
democratic voting rights bill and that's
lisa markowski one republican senator
we'll talk about that number two the
american psychological association is
now apologizing for previously
perpetuating systemic racism what did
they do we'll talk about it is their
apology
substantial uh we will talk about it and
lastly
colorado hospitals are now in a position
where they may need to turn patients
away because of a resurgence in covet
cases and they are going to be allowed
to do it we're going to talk about all
of those stories and more on today's
bonus show which you can get instant
access to by becoming a member at
joinpackman.com if you'd rather do
the pledge via patreon that will also
get you access to the bonus show you can
go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow producerpat will join me
great bonus show otherwise we will be
back tomorrow with another show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman